le népal l'himalaya et ses sommets
mythiques ses huit touristes français en
rêvait dans une heure il ne survoleront
plus ces montagnes ils devront les
gravir il part pour un trek une
randonnée en haute montagne de 23 jours
dans l'himalaya
et ça commence par 40 minutes de stress
sur le vol entre katmandou la capitale
et lukla point de départ de tous les
treks à bord les passagers sont un peu
tendus
avec sa piste incliné à flanc de
montagne c'est l'aéroport le plus
dangereux du monde
aucune tour de contrôle et un crash par
an en moyenne
alors lorsque l'avion se pose sans
encombre
c'est le soulagement
les français vont affronter le trek le
plus mythique du népal jusqu'au camp de
base de l'everest à 5400 mètres une
ascension qu'isabelle après ans marie
d'habitants est vrai qu'il voulait faire
mais bon
on va essayer
sur le tarmac pas le temps de reprendre
ses esprits il faut laisser la place aux
autres touristes qui rentre à katmandou
en pleine saison ce minuscule aéroport
enregistre jusqu'à 60 rotations par jour
et pour cause sept cent mille touristes
viennent gravir chaque année les pentes
de l'himalaya
le trek au népal est une affaire qui
marche
finie la conquête sur la plage les
vacances sont désormais sportive
matériaux plus légers sentiers balisés
partout dans le monde le trek s'est
démocratisée il y en a pour tous les
niveaux et toutes les bourses un
phénomène planétaire mais la référence
absolue celui que toute rigueur rêve de
faire une fois dans sa vie c'est la
route de l'everest en pleine chaîne de
l'himalaya elle commence là où tous les
autres s'arrêtent à 3000 m d'altitude et
se termine dans les cimes de la plus
haute montagne du monde les vagues nous
avons voulu comprendre pourquoi ses
vacances à la dure rencontre un tel
succès au point que les amateurs soient
prêts à casser leur tirelire pour
s'approcher du toit du monde des agences
de voyages ou des populations locales
nous voulons savoir à qui profite cette
nouvelle forme de tourisme et ce
business au sommet
premier briefing avant le départ no 1 8
randonneurs ne partent pas à l'aventuré
ils ont choisi une formule tout compris
avec un guide francophone fort près
celles investies
oui j'espère
et je ne sais d'où sympa et assez
insidieuse la céda et plus que moi c'est
cap pour ce trek no18 touristes ne
seront pas seuls un guide un
ravitailleur et surtout des hommes clés
si cher pas les célèbres porter népalais
plus question pour un touriste de porter
ses affaires personnelles alors il faut
répartir les charges
normalement pour chaque porteur ces 30
kg maximum
130 kg maximum nous verrons plus tard si
toutes les agences respecte ses règles
et surtout dans quelles conditions
travaillent ces porteurs népalais en
attendant c'est le grand départ pour
notre groupe de trekkeurs
ils ont fait plus de 7000 kilomètres
pour atteindre les contreforts népalais
de l'himalaya la haute route de
l'everest par de lukla et grimpe
jusqu'au camp de base des pentes
caillouteuses à brut des sentiers
enneigés trois cols à franchir ce n'est
pas tout à fait de l'alpinisme mais
c'est suffisamment haut pour que michel
et jean jacques se soient équipés de la
déployer
pantalon technique si possible vous êtes
du genre ensuite il est en sous
vêtements inspire en respirant à moi
j'appelle ça main
le pauvre petit paul r ouais après un
coup franc et gore évidemment le sac et
le sac et les lunettes de soleil et
chapeau et surtout des chaussures de
marche qui ne sont pas
deux fois par an je vais chez le
marchand je dois laisser à chaque fois
400 450 ont un peu de ce teaser quand
même pendant trois semaines cité du
matériel qui casse n'est pas certain
pouvoir le repasser en route
avant même de fouler le sol népalais un
trekkeur dépensent en moyenne 1000 euros
en équipement un investissement vite
oublié face à la beauté des paysages
mais le moment le plus attendu celui
pour lequel ils ont fait dix heures
d'avion et des milliers de kilomètres
c'est celui là et là bas au milieu c'est
l'everest
le mont everest
8848 m le sommet le plus haut de la
planète
intéressé longe déposé plainte à un
moment unique durant lequel notre et
coeur se sentent seuls au monde
quelques minutes plus tard ça bouchonne
ça piétine victime de son succès la
route de l'everest est surtout devenue
une autoroute de la grains une surprise
pour michel et isabelle
après quatre heures de marche première
pause déjeuner à table encore un peu de
confort dont il faut profiter dans
quelques jours ce sera sandwich dans la
neige pour ce trek ils ont payé 3200
euros tout compris et que vol repas
hébergement
sort de l'avion s'était fait en charge
mais en fait jean françois et deux
autres participants ont payé 300 euros
de puurs dans san mc ont payé plus
seraient moins chers sont des visages
c'est tout à fait très tôt tous payer
moins cher subtil inscrit dans les
derniers mois donc c'est un peu plus
cher parce que
c'est ce qu'ils nous ont dit on pas des
prix assuré sur catalogue ces accords
gênant comment expliquer de tels écarts
la réponse ne se trouve pas au népal
mais à des milliers de kilomètres
dollars chez le tour opérateur français
qui leur a vendu leur séjour il a son
siège à chapareillan un petit village du
massif de la chartreuse
c'est ici que depuis 38 ans alibert le
leader français élabore tous ces
circuits le trek pour la planète entière
à la tête de la société gérard guerrier
lui même guide de haute montagne donc
ici on a le bâtiment prod c'est lusine
c'est là où on fabrique nos cirques les
le groupe emploie 70 personnes et vend
toute l'année des circuits dans une
centaine de pays brésil afrique à chacun
sa zone
toujours demandé mais le secret du trait
gré eu si ce jour au bout du couloir une
partie importante de la fabrication
l'aérien puisque c'est à peu près un
tiers du coût 10 personnes en relation
permanente avec les grandes compagnies
le prix du trech dépend d'abord du
billet d'avion
un client qui veut partir dans quinze
jours au népal il va avoir un prix
aérien qui va être à peu près de leurs
2400 euros
nous
l'aérien on le touche à peu près entre
800 et 900 euros en moyenne alors
comment on fait sa ba on est on est
joueur de poker
un an à l'as vence on va les voir les
compagnies aériennes on va dire écoutez
on pense que sur cette date là on va
faire 25 clients là sur cette date là 30
clients etc et on s'engage alors en
échange de cet engagement on à des
tarifs très préférentiels et si on
réussit pas à les remplir on a ce qu'on
appelle des pénalités qui peuvent être
parfois très douloureuse les dates de
trek proposé sur le catalogue
correspondent aux billets d'avion
négocier à bas prix un an la vence un
vrai casse tête car le pari c'est de
constituer des groupes de trekkeurs en
fonction des dates de vol qui on a un
groupe de plus de 9 on gagne un peu
d'argent
quand on a des groupes de moins de neuf
on perd de l'argent alors pour éviter ça
les équipes de gérard guerrier font tout
pour constituer des groupes avec le plus
grand nombre de personnes quitte à
changer au dernier moment la date d'un
trek faute de participants
c'est ce qui est arrivé à une partie de
nos randonneurs en fait alibert à
fusionner un groupe de cinq personnes et
un groupe de trois il a donc fallu dans
l'urgence trouver des billets d'avion
sept fois plus cher que le fameux prix
négociés à l'arrivée une différence de
plusieurs centaines d' europe dont une
partie à la charge du client
au final pour un trek au népal à 3200
euros il y à 900 euros pour les billets
d'avion 1700 euros pour le trek
logistique repas hébergement
on arrive à
2602 kouf de coûts directs ce qu'on
appelle les coûts directs puis après ben
nous il faut qu'on se rémunère donc là
c'est pas c'est pas secret l'ensemble
des agences est à peu près 20% 600 euros
pour le voyagiste français une marge
habituel dans la profession mais ce qui
est rarement écrit dans le catalogue
c'est que toute l'organisation sur place
les fameux 1700 euros dépend d'un seul
homme devenu incontournable sur le
marché du trech un népalais qui a fait
de l'himalaya son royaume voici le
travailleur de l'ombre d'allibert sonam
sherpa 51 ans aujourd'hui l'une des plus
grosses fortunes du népal il se déplace
en hélicoptère et possède deux
compagnies locales d'aviation qui ont le
monopole sur les vols vers les zones de
trek
l'himalaya c'est un peu votre terrain de
jeu wii
oui mais
quand je vois toutes ces montagnes et ce
paysage en bas
ça me rappelle mon enfance
j'aime beaucoup revenir par ici
sonam sherpa viens d'une famille très
pauvre de paysans népalais il a gravi
les échelons un à un aujourd'hui ils
organisent la moitié des treks au népal
pour les agences du monde entier son
dernier défi créer des hôtels de
standing dans les endroits les plus
improbables comme celui ci qu'il vient
juste d'inaugurer avec sa vue sidérante
dont il est très fier
c'est l'everest
situé à 4250 m c'est l'un des hôtels les
plus hauts du monde
une fantaisie il rentabilise avec des
services exceptionnels
comme pour ce couple par exemple qui
fait l'aller-retour en deux heures
depuis katmandou simplement pour un
petit déjeuner et une séance photo avec
l'everest en arrière talent
nous sommes venus par hélicoptère avec
un pilote privé seulement nous deux
nous allons repartir
c'est incroyable de voir les vrais ce de
cyprès vous avez payé combien pour ça
nous avons payé 4250 euros mais la cible
de ce navire pas ce n'est pas seulement
ce couple qui peut s'offrir une virée en
hélicoptère hors de prix c'est la
nouvelle clientèle de trekkeurs comme
notre groupe de français sportif certes
mais moins baroudeur
jacking perquis pour un trek dans
l'himalaya
les normalement vous devez marcher
minimum sept à huit heures par j'ai
mon idée en créant ses hôtels ses de
m'adresser à des personnes d'un certain
âge et les des personnes qui préfèrent
marcher quatre heures par jour et qui
ont besoin de confort dans les hôtels
les de kontron
baisse est close les retraités actifs
c'est aujourd'hui la principale
clientèle du trek ils ont du temps et
surtout les moyens de s'offrir des
chambres confortables et pour s'être et
coeur d'un nouveau genre il n'a pas
hésité à investir un million d'euros
dans cet hôtel comme dans les cinq
autres qu'ils possèdent fini le trek
sous la tente et dans le froid place au
nid douillet
ça c'est une chambre confortable
alors voilà là vous avez une couverture
électrique chauffant est inquiète vous
pouvez régler la température si vous
avez froid brochet et ça coûte combien
pour un groupe c'est 120 euros et pour
un client seul ses 150 euros la nuit il
vaut mieux faire partie d'un groupe tout
à fait si sonam sherpa n'a pas de mal à
remplir ses hôtels c'est qu'en 25 ans il
est devenu l'aiguilleur du trech de tous
les voyagistes de la planète et sa tour
de contrôle se trouve 3000 mètres plus
bas à quatre temps doux dans une
luxueuse maison coloniale
voici la plus grosse agence du royaume
uni ça c'est alibert la plus grosse
française
et eux ce sont des espagnols
les tours opérateurs du monde entier
passe personnel sherpa
c'est un département français sa société
est connecté 24 heures sur 24 avec le
voyagiste français et peut voir les
réservations en temps réel what we show
une fois que le nouveau catalogue
d'allibert est publié nous avons accès à
leurs systèmes internet
ils nous ont fourni tous leurs codes
d'entrée tous les codes confidentiels
est alors en direct nous voyons toutes
les réservations confirmées celles qui
sont non confirmées les personnes qui
ont payé un trek celles qui n'ont pas
encore payé l' agence française se
contente de lui envoyer les clients et
sauna morgan as to
book nous réservons les porter nous
commandons toute la nourriture et gérons
toute la logistique
nous réservons des guides des guides qui
parlent français
nous prenons les assurances et nous nous
occupons de toutes les réservations
d'hôtel à l'arrivée notre marge est de
10 à 15%
avec 4000 clients par an
cette sous traitance lui rapporterait
environ 800 mille euros entre le billet
d'avion le voyagiste est l'organisateur
du trek la facture s'élève en principe à
3200 euros mais sur le chemin les
randonneurs vont très bien d'autres
tentations qui vont faire grimper la
note et en premier lieu la bouteille
d'eau minérale dans un pays sans eau
potable
la population locale a vite compris
qu'elle était indispensable pour un
trekkeur 80 puis 100 roupies 80 centimes
le prix augmente le long du parcours
savard compter en montant au fur et à
mesure
mais les plus grandes tentations notre
hacker les rencontres à mi-parcours à
namche bazaar la capitale des sherpas
le dernier village commerçants avant le
grand désert de nage
aussi un secteur tourne à plein régime
celui de l'équipement de haute montagne
a
été mieux seul que j'ai vu à l'entrée du
village c'est un homme chez bazar nous
retrouvons jean jacques et christian du
groupe alibert qui s'offre une journée
shopping jean-jacques a repéré une
petite facebook c'est ça voilà c'est ça
parce que ça c'est coupe-vent et 1950
09 euros en france une veste comme ça
c'est 50 euros 55 euros une veste
coupe-vent siglé d'une grande marque
cinq fois moins cher qu'en france il
n'hésite pas une seconde
mais à la caisse il n'est pas dupe
c'est du vrai north face
yes et le sourire de la vendeuse vous en
dit long sur l'origine de cette fameuse
veste
au népal la marque américaine qui tient
son nom de la plus difficile face de
l'everest est une institution dans
chaque magasin il y a toujours des
produits neufs s ata mail le quartier
touristique de katmandou
des centaines de boutiques 27 marques
comme celle de neil âme et avec les
clients il est plutôt honnête sur ce
qu'il vend
tous ses vêtements ce sont des faux
c'est très troublant on sait plus ce qui
est vrai et ce qui est faux je préfère
les prix du faux
si on peut avoir l'original avec le prix
du faux alors ça c'est bien
[Rires]
c'est un anorak coûte entre 40 et 50
euros c'est un bon business qui marche
très bien et j'en vends tous les joueurs
vraiment tous les jours chaque mois il
réalise une marge de cinq cents euros
soit dix fois plus que le salaire moyen
au népal de la contrefaçon qui rapporte
et connie la mère comme un chef
d'entreprise et à grande échelle il
accepte de nous emmener dans son arrière
boutique qui a des allures
d'ateliers clandestins
le tissu directement importées de chine
et transformé ici en fonte produit dans
space made in n'aime pas
une parka comme la mienne j'en fabrique
7 par jour et ce sac de couchage ça
prend 10 on allait un jour
wallays nous découvrons aussi des
ouvriers payés 5 euros la pièce au
mépris des règles élémentaires de
sécurité
faute d'éclairage appropriée c'est la
bougie qui fait à la fois lumière et
coupe file pour ses sacs de couchage
ici le moindre recoin est utilisé pour
la contrefaçon et il ya des ouvriers
dans chaque pièce des machines à coudre
ont même été installé sur le balcon par
manque de place et ni l'âme soigne les
apparences jusque sur les étiquettes
faible et le népal au népal
mais ce dont 1000 âmes est très fier
c'est sa machine à tisser ultramoderne
qui fabrique à la chaîne et fologo n'a
pas de problème avec l'autorité
non je n'ai pas de problème
parce qu'au népal il ya de la
concurrence c'est le business le
gouvernement nous nous interdit pas de
faire ce qu'on fait cela ne me pose pas
le moindre problème
des autorités qui ferment les yeux mais
aussi encore plus incroyable la première
victime la marque elle-même à 500 mètres
de l'entreprise denis l'âme voici la
boutique officielle north face elle est
gérée par sabine a pendant longtemps
elle a été obligée de mettre bien en
évidence sur le comptoir cet écriteau en
bois histoire de rassurer les clients
sur la marchandise car pour le reste
le prix est presque trois fois plus
élevé 125 euros cette doudoune alors que
ni la mule avant 50 euros et
curieusement elle ne vois pas où est le
problème je ne suis pas justement la
gérante de la boutique officielle
vous savez je suis aussi népalaise ces
magasins qui vendent du faux il était là
bien avant ma naissance
alors vous savez en tant que népalaise
je ne vois pas du tout en tenter une
action pour les mettre dehors
sauf que dans la boutique de sabina il
n'y a pas foule
vous êtes combien de vendeuse nous
sommes seulement trois vendeuses vous
êtes donc plus nombreuses que les
clients aujourd'hui effectivement malgré
ce manque à gagner
la marque ne s'est pas encore attaqué la
contrefaçon qui fait vivre une partie du
pays au final entre le forfait pour un
trek et tous les à côtés les vacances
peuvent donc finir par coûter cher y at
il un moyen de dépenser moins en fait il
est possible d'organiser son trek tout
seul est pour beaucoup moins cher dans
les rues de nam chez bazar on rencontre
de nombreux voyageurs solitaires comme
jean-luc 55 ans ce retraité actif n'est
pas passer par une agence
il a prévu de dépenser 1500 euros pour
45 jours de marche soit sur place
presque deux fois moins que notre groupe
d'albert à chaque étape il doit trouver
lui-même un endroit où dormir et ce jour
là il est plutôt content de sa chambre
car il ya une salle de bain
c'est ça oui jusqu'à maintenant on a
marché 14 jours elle à chaque fois c'est
sous une douche dehors
faut sortir pour aller à la douche pour
aller aux toilettes il ya des douches
c'est un seau d'eau chaude elle la
chambre est aussi à 100 roupies
la chambre soit 80 centimes d'euro
desautels comme celui là il y en a des
dizaines à namche bazaar
bonjour vous avez une chambre
c'est 200 roupies pour la chambre 1
euros 70 la chambre un prix imbattable
mais tout le reste est en supplément une
douche chaude pour une douche chaude
c'est 300 roupies
donc 200 + 300 au total 500 oui c'est ça
2 euros cinq ans pour une douche chaude
plutôt nécessaire lorsqu'il peut faire 5
degrés dehors même en été des chambres
simples mais sans chauffage et sans
électricité et pour recharger ses
batteries le touriste devra payer encore
presque 1 euro de l'heure quant aux
toilettes c'est dans la cabane au fond
de la cour
les toilettes sont dehors et la douche
aussi et allées froides
à froide bien sûr si l'hébergement sur
place revient moins cher un vrai piège
guette ceux qui veulent se débrouiller
seul il concerne la durée du trek nous
faisons passer pour des randonneurs
amateurs qui souhaitent à l'est de
katmandou au camp de base de l'everest
pour faire baisser le prix nous
demandons à faire le trajet en seulement
huit jours au lieu de 13 la première
agence semble sérieuse et nous met en
garde ce n'est pas possible aussi
envie jours ce n'est pas possible
combien de jours il faut au minimum 13
jours si quelqu'un vous raconte que vous
pouvez y aller en huit jours il raconte
n'importe quoi il veut seulement vous
arnaquer et vous voler votre argent
mais dans d'autres agences le discours
est radicalement différent de 82 au camp
de base en cinq jours c'est possible oui
en cinq jours c'est possible
oui oui c'est possible c'est possible
c'est possible cinq jours pour monter et
trois agents pour descendre
toutes ses agences locales vont nous
proposer des prises assez attractif qui
oscille entre 700 et 1000 euros tout
compris mais en cas de problème ça se
complique
si on tombe malade à cause de l'altitude
et qu'on doit revenir on est remboursé
non malheureusement
des agences prête à tout pour vendre un
trek à marche forcée et dont les
victimes ne sont pas seulement les
clients mais aussi en bout de chaîne les
porter
dans notre groupe de trekkeurs français
ils sont six à transporter les affaires
des touristes
ceux là sont plutôt bien payé 12 euros
par jour soit deux fois plus que le
salaire minimum des sherpas ce jour là
ils accélèrent la cadence même avec leur
charge de 30 kilos sur le dos après sept
heures de marche ils sont pressés
d'arriver pour se reposer comme chaque
soir ils déposent les bagages à l'hôtel
ou endormir les français mais pas eux
c'est dans le bas du village qu'ils vont
passer la nuit dans cette pièce où il
dort tous ensemble à même le sol
chaque soir quand on arrive quelque part
on doit se débrouiller pour trouver un
endroit où dormir
mais ces porteurs sont contents de leur
sort sonam sherpa leur paye aussi une
assurance et travailler pour des
touristes reste une bonne affaire
quand tu travailles pour un employé pas
pour une agence de trek tu dois porter
des charges très très lourde des payer
50 centimes et à la fois après avoir
payé ta nourriture tu peux même pas
économisé 15 centimes
en agence était payant entre 6 euros
c'est le minimum et 12 euros là pour le
coup c'est bien mais les conditions de
travail restent difficiles et il existe
des abus aux conséquences dramatiques
à 20 ans suresh garde un très mauvais
souvenir de son trek il n'est d'ailleurs
pas prêt de recommencer
il habite avec son oncle stoupas taman
amputé des deux jambes en 2009 alors
qu'ils participaient tous les deux un
trek avec des touristes américains
dans la montagne
tout là-haut j'étais avec mes amis
et puis j'ai ressenti quelque chose de
bizarre
j'avais le mal des montagnes
je dis à mes amis à les y continuer sans
moi j'arrive à
mes amis sont donc partis mais moi
j'avais toujours ce mal des montagnes
et puis je me suis perdu j'ai pris le
mauvais chemin la neige tombée et puis à
la fin je ne pouvais plus marcher il n'y
avait pas d'abri j'ai vu un rocher je me
suis posé là et j'attends du l'accès est
impossible par hélicoptère il sera
retrouvé au bout de deux jours les
jambes gelé lagence qui l'employait ne
lui avait pas fourni un bon équipement
pour ce trek dans la neige
vous acheter des chaussures des
chaussettes oui j'avais des chaussures
mais ce n'était pas des chaussures
montantes ça ne vous protégez pas les
jambes et les chevilles non ça ne
protégeait pas du tout c'est dur
aujourd'hui vous savez je ne souhaite à
personne ce qui m'arrive pour ce travail
stoupas taman a été payé 500 roupies par
jules 4 euros 50
existe-t-il au népal un syndicat qui
défend ces forçats de l'himalaya pas
vraiment
mais depuis quelques années une
association de sauveteurs dénonce
certaines pratiques à sa tête tracas
chadi caries selon lui les accidents de
porteurs restent fréquents
sur la photo vous avez un porter malade
qui est évacué
hélas le mal des montagnes il est placé
sous oxygène
se porter la il est devenu aveugle
marcher dans la neige sans lunettes de
soleil mais l'état n'a jamais imposé des
règles claires
l'état devrait instaurer des règles car
le trek en montagne c'est très important
pour le tourisme l'état ne devrait pas
oublier les porter
malgré tout les salaires ont augmenté
ces dernières années les agences
semblent avoir compris le rôle clé des
sherpas pour faire marcher le tourisme
[Musique]
car sans eux
notre groupe de trekkeurs français
n'aurait certainement pas réussi son
ascension jusqu'au sommet
c'est le bronze
après quatorze jours de marche ils
atteignent à bout de souffle le mythique
camp de base de l'everest à 5400 mètres
d'altitude
[Musique]
monde mais alors quelle vue magnifique
un everest avec son col sud fantastique
il leur faudra neuf jours pour
redescendre mais avec en tête le
souvenir de cette vue unique sur le toit
du monde une aventure qui au final a
peut-être un coup mais qui pour eux là
pas de prix